[موسيقى]
تتناقض فلسفتنا في الواقع مع
صناعة اللياقة البدنية بأكملها ، حسنًا ،
يأتي تدريب صناعة اللياقة البدنية بالكامل أولاً ،
تأتي الحركة أولاً على ما يرام ، ثمانون في المائة
من نتائج عملائنا تأتي من
التدريب وليس من النظام الغذائي الذي لدينا
نظام منهجي ويسمى
تدريب الانشطار والاندماج  حيث أقوم بتدريبات لأجزاء
الجسم مع تدريب كامل للجسم ،
لدينا قيود طفيفة للغاية ،
سأطلب من عميلي ، نعم ،
ما الذي تريده في قائمة
وجبة الإفطار والغداء والعشاء المفضلة لديك ، حسنًا
، سوف يكتبون ذلك وسأخبرهم
مقدار ما يمكن أن يحصلوا
عليه وهذا ما تعلمه للتنافس مع
رقائق الشركات الكبيرة هذه ، كان علي أن أفعل
عكس ما يفعلونه عكس
ما يفعلونه هو أنهم يتقاضون رسومًا منخفضة
جدًا ولديهم مساحات كبيرة جدًا وأنا
أتقاضى رسومًا  رسوم عالية جدًا
ولدي مساحة صغيرة جدًا ، أعني أنها حقيقة
أنني أغلى
مدرب في الإمارات أو أعلى أجورًا في
الإمارات والسبب الذي يجعلهم يرون
نتائج غيرت حياتهم هو  لأنهم في
تلك الأيام الـ 28 في برنامج Ultra هذا ،
يسلمون حياتهم بأكملها ،
لا يذهبون إلى العمل ،
حسنًا ، ما أقول إن جدولهم بين
يدي ، كل شيء في
يدي قد أضعهم في غرفة فندق وأضعهم
في  الكاميرا ، سأفعل أي شيء يتطلبه الأمر
لضمان اتباعهم للخطة ،
ومن الواضح أن التدريب باهظ التكلفة في
هذا الالتزام يعني أنه يجب أن أكون
على استعداد لقبول العميل وأعني
أنني أعلم أنني لن أقبل 99٪ من
الأشخاص الذين سيقبلون  حاول أن ترغب في ذلك
لأنه سيستغرق
مني الكثير كما هو خارجهم ، فأنا أرفض العملاء
طوال اليوم لأنه يتعين عليك طيهم ،
وعليك تصفية العملاء الذين لا يمكننا التعامل مع
أي شخص ليس الجميع
مستعدًا  من أجل التزام النظام
بالبيئة والجو ، فإن حقيقة
أنني أعارض الحبوب في كل حافلة
تقريبًا مع كل قادة أساسيين